A magnitude 7.5 earthquake rocked parts of Afghanistan and Pakistan,...
...killing more than 200 people and injuring 1,000 or more.
In Turkey, a raid on an Islamic State cell in the mainly Kurdish city of Diyarbakir...
...left two Turkish police officers and seven militants dead.
Thousands gather in the German city of Dresden for an anti-Islam PEGIDA rally...
...as migrants mostly from the Middle East continue to pour into the European Union.
In South Korea, North and South Korean families divided since the Korean War...
...say a tearful farewell, wrapping up a rare family reunion.
And finally from France, the World Health Organization says eating processed meats...
...such as ham, sausage, bacon and hotdogs can cause cancer.